Now we've presented our
DiceViewController in three different
ways; programatically, using
a combination of code and Storyboard,
and entirely in Storyboard.
Recall that in the first solution,
the incoming instance of
DiceViewController is
manipulated directly.
The current view controller has a chance
to prepare the incoming view controller
and what did that preparation involve?
The roll view controller sets the two
dice values on the dice view controller.
When we use a segue the dice view
controller never makes an appearance in
our code because story board
hides the creation of the object.
So now we need a new hook to allow
communication between the two view
controllers.
The method we need is
called prepareForSegue.
All view controllers
inherit this method and
it's invoked right before
any segue is performed.
Its entire purpose is to allow
the current view controller to configure
the incoming object.